if you want to have respect if you want
people to listen to you then you need to
have the confidence to go in and know
what you're talking about and put on an
aura that people are attracted to
otherwise they're going to walk all over
you and you're not going to get the
deals that you deserve and build a
company that you deserve hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today I
made some question from one of my
youtube viewers I think her name is
Charlotte who wrote an essay question
for you Evan do you know why ladies are
not taking seriously as business owners
I'm on a locksmith company my husband
does lock and safe work when he
introduces me to people he has met other
business owners they are polite but
seemed to gear towards him for
conversation please help Thank You
Charlotte Charlotte it's not because
you're a woman it's because you are not
giving yourself enough confidence going
into the meeting I used to have the same
problem i had my first software company
i was 19 years old the first business
that i really had and i was selling the
guys were three times my age who had
PhDs and who had years of work
experience and at first i wasn't able to
make sales and I thought it's because I
was too young you know I'm only 19 what
do I know these guys have a ton of
experience and I didn't get the sales
and it wasn't until I changed my
perspective and realized that I can help
these guys and that I had the confidence
behind what I was selling my presence
change my aura changed and i started
making sales i got past the limiting
personal belief that young entrepreneurs
aren't taken seriously you go in a new
command respect if you come in with a
confidence then people will respect you
i know a ton of women entrepreneurs who
have great businesses and who command
respect you start off right away with do
you know why ladies are not taking
seriously as business owners right there
is your problem that's you're
eliminating person belief it's not true
tons of ladies are taking seriously it's
a confident ones it's one who believe in
what they're doing and the ones who
demand and command respect if you're
going into these meetings you have to
know you're the owner you have to have
confidence in what you're doing and not
let other people dominate the
conversation and maybe easier for them
to talk to your husband because
they've already done work with him but
if you're talking on an owner to owner
level you have to go in with the
confidence knowing that what you're
saying is right and that you are the
decision maker if you do that people
will listen to you you have to break
through that limiting person believe
it's not your husband's fault it's not
the other business owners fault it's not
the fact that you're a woman it's you
that's the truth you got to get over
that thing that limiting person believe
that's holding you back and that will
empower you and that's a message that
you want to take for yourself if you
have daughters you want to pass it on to
them it is other women entrepreneurs in
your family you want to pass it on to
them as well being a woman is not a bad
thing it will not hold you back there's
no excuse except the story you're
telling yourself good luck for those of
you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more for you and I
want to hear all you have to say you
have a comment leave it below and I love
seeing the comments coming that makes my
morning every day and if you have a
question for your business always also
leave in the comments section below I
always read those and I will hopefully
make a video reply for you guys thank
you and I'll see you soon